[Music]
walking up the ramp walking through the
hallway I flashback to when I was a kid
and with the action figures inside
suddenly I had like a big lump in my
throat Brian is doing many unexpected
things and taking characters in new
directions individual stories of these
characters are elevated and made fresh
in you that's what I love about Brian's
approach to the story it's like a real
journey of discovery
is and gentlemen welcome to episode 8
first time shooting with mark first time
Shane with Daisy
first time shooting a Star Wars movie
and we got some cool stuff
sad like a dog whimper Ryan's wonderful
personality is all over this phone
I've misjudged this he has flaws in
other areas I just don't know about
there's the weird thing that happens
when it's being built when you first
show up on it here's kind of over
battles fight at all and then you get
into the nitty-gritty of working on it
ready
and naturally that level of it goes away
and you find yourself just focused on
making the scene work getting the shots
and then once in a while you're taking a
little break and sitting back and you
look around
to get the holy crap Jernigan
concentrators works split up five holy
craps
[Music]
hey beautiful and very nice guy when I
found you I saw raw untamed power and
beyond that something very special
[Applause]
[Music]
something beside me has always been
[Music]
but I was awake
[Music]
[Music]
I've seen this roster only once before
it just scared me enough that
it doesn't know
[Music]
the pastime
if you have to
that's the only way to become a human
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the fire
this is not going to go
[Music]
the way you think
Oh
yes honey
finding someone to show me my place in
all this
[Music]
[Music]